foreign
we cope in different ways
so to put this down I need my hands free
do you need to talk with your hands so
much
yes I feel like it's been forever since
I've done a spoiler video in a case like
this though I feel it's very important
to examine the body so if you haven't
seen dial of Destiny by now this is my
spoiler Talk video gonna talk about some
spoilers not going to be a play-by-play
but just going to talk about some things
I couldn't talk about in my spoiler-free
review now before I get into it what I
appreciated Harrison Ford the man's a
professional he clocks into work Ian
Matt's Mickelson both in fact
most 99 of the people in here are great
in here I Gotta Give It Up to Harrison
Ford though 80 years old still in top
shape still going at it now I will talk
about how they made Indiana Jones an old
grumpy version of Indiana Jones who
literally knocks on his neighbor's door
like pounds on the door tells him keep
the music down but it doesn't mean
Harrison Ford doesn't put in the work
how a character is written what the
script does with the character and the
actor's effort two different things I do
appreciate that that said let's take a
breath let's get into it now like I said
in my spoiler free review the first 20
minutes of this movie that's the movie
the whole segment dealing with de-aged
Indiana Jones who sounds like old
Indiana Jones it was so funny it's like
young Harrison Ford he's like a Nazi Fox
paraphrasing but he still does he still
had the gruff groggly old man voice I
almost promise you that when this movie
has its home release the next day some
fan out there is going to da age
Harrison Ford's voice and make him sound
Young And Then There we go and then
lucasfilm will hire that person but that
DH deep fake young Indiana Jones face is
a lot of people have bitched about it
more than me because it bothered them
more than it bothered me but all in all
the spirit of Adventure and essence of
Indiana Jones did feel like Indiana
Jones as he was in the original trilogy
then we fast forward to 1969. funny
thing here's a little quiz for you
character has his happy ending with his
wife and son then they lose their son
and that loss breaks up their marriage
and now character is an old grumpy
version of himself who am I talking
about Han Solo or Indiana Jones it's a
trick question it's both it's so weird
that's what lucasfilm does with Harrison
Ford characters apparently any school
student who did that kind of copy and
paste from one report to the next report
the teacher would be like no no you have
to do a new one you can't just copy and
paste the old one do it again unless
you're writing a Harrison Ford plague
character for Disney lucasfilm in which
case that would be fine so now Indy
teams up with his goddaughter played by
Phoebe Waller Bridge who plays the
daughter of his friend played by Toby
Jones so my spoiler free review I was
like they could have made the dynamic
between these two work because you know
Indy is an old grumpy [__] and she's
kind of a miserable [__] herself and
they could have leaned into that and
said hey we're helping each other be a
little happier in this adventure that
said they didn't do that and she
absolutely came across as arrogant tries
to act overconfident not in an
organically confident way but in that
way insecure people try to posture
confidence just comes across as hubris
makes the person seem completely
unlikable like you don't want to hang
out with him for two and a half hours he
yeah that and that's beside the fact
that when she's not selling
archaeological artifacts to underground
Black Market scumbags she's locking the
cage trying to get Indy killed oh but
they're supposed to be Pals and I felt
like John Malkovich from knock around
guys you are unlikable tell you who was
awesome Shawnette Renee Wilson is the
CIA agent if you need a female character
to team up with Indiana Jones the setup
with her was absolutely there she's a
CIA agent going after Indiana Jones and
then the other CIA agents she's working
with start killing people and she's like
what the [__] is that dude that's not
how we do it turns out the other CIA
agent she's working with are mads
Mickelson's Nazi goons so she could have
been like screw this noise Dr Jones were
teaming up we have a common interest we
have a common goal we've got to stop
them and they've infiltrated the CIA
it's personal to both of them at this
point why not have them both team up
also more interesting setup rather than
be like yeah he had this friend that we
never heard about and that friend had a
daughter that we never seen before trust
us goddaughter they're close they're not
so I've seen internet talk a lot about
this and I agree Short Round teaming up
with Indy for this final Adventure would
have been awesome would have been a cool
bookend too since in terms of the
timeline of Indiana Jones Adventures
Temple of Doom takes place before
Raiders of the Lost Ark so it's like
Indy's first adventure and his final
Adventure are both an adventure with him
in Short Round And you know that
scenario was brought up too I would love
to see the round table discussion as to
why he was not brought into this film
the film is done it's in the cat and it
comes out in mere months and I must say
we made the right call
[Music]
um
oh he just won an Oscar
I thought I'd love to be a fly on that
wall so Shia LaBeouf not coming back as
much I get that but
you remember that concept called
recasting it's almost like that's a
thing Hollywood's forgotten is even
possible can you imagine a world after
Iron Man won it was like oh well Terence
Howard is out as roadie
guess we gotta kill the character in a
car wreck or whatever now you recast the
character you move on having mutt be
played by another actor could totally
work it's also been 15 years that's kind
of advantageous like it doesn't look
exactly it's been 15 years but if you're
gonna not have him in the movie have
writing him out makes sense for the
character not every 30-something 40 year
old man has to be hanging out with his
80 year old father for every Adventure
you could just have it be like oh yeah
he's in Montana with his family
hanging out doing his thing no there
wasn't even a Fallout I see him on the
holidays we talk all the time I wrestle
with the grandkids it's fine but then if
you do that you won't have Indy be
grumpy and sad I guess that's what
they're going for point is why have his
character join the war
his dude he was part of the fight The
Establishment crew you know it just
didn't make any sense to have his
character join the war he didn't get
drafted he signed up if you're gonna
kill his character kill him in a car
wreck like a decent stupid script so
fast forwarding passed all the CGI
scenery and CGI Chase sequences that
weren't really exciting to me because
CGI Chase sequences we get to the dial
of Destiny so the dial of Destiny is
based off of the anti-cathra device I
believe I'm pronouncing that correctly I
hope so and if not that's pretty par for
the chorus actually a pretty miraculous
and amazing device that shouldn't exist
per when it came from best people can
figure this device that's thousands of
years old as the world's oldest computer
wild but for the sake of the movie dial
of Destiny it can sniff out fissures in
time so you can fly through these tears
in time like you're looking for The
Langoliers or some [__] because mads
Mickelson's character who's the only one
who sells this premise by the way he's
like I'm gonna go back in time I'm going
to kill hit I'm going to take over and
then I'm going to win World War II it's
actually pretty scary you don't want
that to happen so let's get to it let's
stop them they go through this Terror in
time they find no Langoliers but they do
find Archimedes because they've flown 2
000 years into the past the whole Army
there thinks that these planes are
dragons as they start attacking them I
actually did like that detail in here
it's like oh yeah they would see planes
as dragons why would they not it's a
problem I have with it is the fact that
they go back in time
and Indy's pretty much like I have been
shot I think I'm gonna stay here yeah I
just want to die Phoebe Waller Bridge's
character is like no you can't you're
gonna die of dysentery while forwarding
a river is like you know you can't do it
you're gonna die of infection he's like
just let me die and she's like sorry pow
knocks him out it fades and then he's
back in his apartment Karen Allen comes
in and Phoebe Waller Bridge's character
and Salah who's a cab driver now
they'll take off Sala starts singing
Because you know Raiders Nostalgia bait
and they're like that's not enough
Nostalgia bait they'll have Indy and
Mary and have the conversation where
does it hurt here kiss the elbow here
because you know like they do that whole
thing there are rumors out there that
there was an original ending that they
then re-filmed a new ending to James
Mangold says no that's not true and John
Williams said oh yeah I had to do a new
score there's like a whole don't know
don't care because they don't know what
the original ending if there was one was
at all I do know that everything post
knock Indie out from him waking up in
his apartment to all the Nostalgia bait
that just stumbles into the end feels
like an ending that was written in about
four and a half minutes if that it's
just like all right
solid Nostalgia bait Marian Nostalgia
bait Fade to the Hat the end so that's
the flyby going back and talking about
the problems I have with the end of this
movie is that it doesn't line up with
Indiana Jones first of all it's too
clean Indy always had this element of oh
archeology and mystery and enchantment
and horror faces melting Hearts getting
ripped out dude becomes the Crypt Keeper
even Kate blanchett's character wants
all the knowledge she gets all the
knowledge she can't handle it her eyes
glow and Flame up and she turns to dust
this movie has nothing like that they go
through this ripping time talk to
Archimedes India's like I want to stay
she's like nope boom knocks him out he
wakes up in his shitty apartment it just
bothered me that the ending of this
movie came across as such a clean
version of an Indiana Jones ending that
didn't feel like an Indiana Jones ending
the concept the argument against Indy
staying there is that she's like you
can't stay here you're gonna screw up
time of course India's like well that'd
be so bad but they found the tomb of
Archimedes earlier and Archimedes had
drawings of phoenixes with propellers on
them planes and he had a watch that he
gets from them the fact that they found
that before they went into the past
implies what's going to happen has
already happened you can't change it you
can't alter the past you're just
fulfilling Destiny thus leaving India in
the past wouldn't lead to a present any
different than the one you already know
if you leave him in the past the present
you have is because you left him in the
past and it always was always has been
always will be the case if they found
the tomb and Archimedes did not have a
watch or drawings of airplanes and then
maybe that tomb did have those after
they had gotten back then yeah you can
change the past like Back to the Future
but the fact that those changes were
already there before they even went to
the past that speaks to a different
thing I don't think leaving Indy there
would change the past at all or change
the present at all I mean it's a
question for the philosophers but I do
think the way the movie set up time with
the watch in the Tomb before they went
back into the past it raises a question
as to whether or not leaving Indy there
would actually change anything choice is
a very important thing in the hero's
journey you know Indiana Jones trying to
reach for the Holy Grail and his dad's
like Let It Go and he's like you're
right I have to let it go I have to make
that choice Han Solo taking his money
and just flying off being like peace
have fun with that death star and have
fun dying and then having the choice
being like
I should go back and help them imagine
if in Temple of Doom you know India
wanted to go after the stones because he
wanted his Fame and glory and you're
right it was going to be his big moment
and he elected to give the stone back to
the town because it was the right thing
to do but imagine he gets the stone and
then Willy's just like nope pow then he
wakes up and she's like I gave the stone
back to the townspeople because it was
the right thing to do the ending of this
movie kind of lands like that in a way
so I watched Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull after I did my spoiler free review
of dial the destiny I was like I should
just pop that in and watch it again so I
dusted off that disc I called a coaster
put it in and I watched it I think
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull is better
than dial of Destiny I feel there's a
very solid argument for that they
actually both run into the same
negatives over Reliance on CGI
noticeable green screen so when
comparing the two movies those kind of
cancel each other out so looking at
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull the
Grievances that movie has are moments
nuke fridge dumb but on the other hand
pretty memeable I've shown people that
just be like you want to laugh check
this out Shia LaBeouf swinging on vines
that's a moment and then it's done you
never have to see it again the kingdom
of the Crystal Skull has a pretty sweet
motorcycle chase sequence it's better
than any of the chase sequences I saw in
dial of Destiny the pacing is also much
tighter it's location location and
location we're in the last Act the movie
ends dial of Destiny is a half an hour
too long has too many locations just
tries to feel too big for the adventure
we're on I don't need these big green
screen locations big green screen city
streets put us in the jungle ancient
Greece have some baddies with guns
coming after us just
just be practical about it at the very
least have good pacing but the biggest
thing is Indiana Jones and Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull still felt like an
older Indie but Indy nonetheless style
of Destiny Indie feels like yeah we have
to have an aged Indie because Harrison
Ford has indeed aged a bright idea let's
have him feel about as fun and
adventurous as Clint Eastwood from Gran
Torino so that's where I am with dial of
Destiny if you want to compare it to
Crystal Skull Crystal Skull flawed but
maintain the spirits
of Indiana Jones it's just kind of it's
Lucas and Spielberg of that era a lot of
CGI cheesier than the property had been
at times but the spirit is there it is
great to see Harrison Ford back donning
the whip but the character just doesn't
feel like the character to me in a world
where escapism of Cinema is a thing I
don't think Indiana Jones had to meet us
on the train to grumpy foxville just
because we're gonna get there I get why
he's grumpy they killed his kid he lost
his marriage it's
why would he not Bae it is funny to me
that it feels like Harrison Ford is
putting in the work but Indiana Jones
the character doesn't feel like he wants
to be on this adventure dial of Destiny
feels like a very safe clean sterile too
long in the run time and ultimately less
interesting Indiana Jones fanfic all
right so Disney Anna Jones and the dial
of Destiny have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]
thank you